مجزره اسراليه جديده بحق المدنيين العزل
هنا في المنطقه الشرقيه الجنوبيه لخان
يونس بعد قصف هذه البنايه وبنايات مجاوره
من قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه دون
سابق انذار هذا الامر ادى الى استشهاد على
الاقل 30 فلسطينيا معظمهم من الاطفالي
والنساء وايضا مازال عدد اخر مفقود تحت
ركام هذه البنايه كما تشاهدون امامكم في
هذا المشهد هذا هو المنزل ومحيطه ومنازل
دمرت وهذه البنايه المكونه من عده طوابق ل
ئله معمر قصفت دون سابق انذار من قبل
الطيران الحربي لص الامر الذي ادى الى
ارتقاء نحو 30 شهيدا بينهم اطفال بينهم
بطبيعه الحال نساء القصف كان دون سابق
انذار يجري الحديث هنا عن اناس فقدوا اسفل
ركام هذه البنايه التي جرى قصفها بكل
تاكيد كما تشاهدون لا يوجد اي معدات حتى
هذه اللحظه للبحث وعمليه الانتشال نظرا
حتى لصعوبه التنقل وصعوبه التحرك من قبل
المواطنين هنا في هذا المكان الواقع على
شارع صلاح الدين في المنطقه القريبه من
المشفى الاوروبي شرقي مدينه خانيونس جنوبي
قطاع غزه هذه المنطقه يعني من المفترض
انها من المناطق الامنه ولم تنذر القوات
الاسرائيليه احدا بالاخلاء او الخروج منها
وبالتالي نزح اليها السكان من مختلف مدينه
خان يونس وكذلك مناطق عده في مدينه غزه
ايضا وفي مدينه رفح اتوا الى هذه المنطقه
ظنا منهم انها امنه وبكل تاكيد من بين
شهداء هذا المنزل هم من النازحين بقولوا
ام ههنا في الامان في كل غزه في الشمال
على الفاضي يهجرنا عم يهجرنا بدون ما
يقتلونا مش عارف ايش احكي انا والله ما
عارف ايش اقول 50 ولد صغ 50 طفل صغار
الليله في المستشفى مزقل الصغار المصابين
والنسوان حرقوهم حرق نسوان وصغار لا في
مقاومين ولا في فش حد مش عارف وين نروح
والله ماني عارف قتل بالجمله حصيله طبيعيه
للغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه العنيفه
المتواصله على قطاع لليوم الس على التوالي
هاني الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه خان يونس